welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and the killer show
mind hunter is finally back on Netflix
with its second season that arguably
cuts one of the most psychological
studies ever put to TV throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about season to
its ending and where the show could be
going in the future there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to watch mine don't yet and don't
want to know what happens then I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into my breakdown of mine hunter
season 2 the first season of mind hunter
followed Holden Ford in built hench as
they slowly established the behavioral
science unit that studied the
compulsions that created serial killers
by interviewing them directly the work
was pretty shunned early on but after
solving several cases through the use of
insight gained from the offenders they
were able to slowly build profiles that
defined killers whilst also gaining
backing from institutions however Holden
found himself slowly alienating the
other parts of his life due to the
fascination of the killers and in the
final episode he found himself isolated
and almost on a friendship level with
the people that he was studying he lost
his girlfriend arrogantly stormed out of
meetings and seemed to be approaching
the dark side this came to a head when
Edmund Kemper the most infamous killer
of the first season hooked him said they
were friends and this sent him into a
panic attack juxtaposing season worn due
to a new director the FBI are far more
accepting of the studies and even goes
so far to make them standard practice in
the department however that doesn't mean
it's all plain sailing as it's clearly
stay that this change up is due to
Holden's actions in the first season
after his panic attack we start to think
that the work may be having a negative
effect on Holden's help this experience
and it's somewhat fall from grace
humbles Holden but there's still a
fascination that exists there with the
McCobb it's very much a case of if you
gaze into the abyss the abyss gazes back
and the dangers in this season come from
all directions
BTK gets an expanded role and becomes a
huge focus early on Son of Sam pops up
to offer insight
Charles Manson make
unforgettable appearance and the Atlanta
child murders become a huge focus and
the ongoing investigations
the latter really drives season two and
the unit is called into investigating
the brutal attacks themselves there is a
desperate attempt to draw the killer
into the open in order to end the spree
as quickly as possible
now the Atlanta murders themselves took
place from 1979 all the way until 1981
and involved the murder of at least 28
children and adults this wave of crime
forces Ford to create a controversial
psychological profile of the killer that
states he will be black which doesn't go
down too well he surmises this due to
instincts but it's brushed it aside
because it could heighten the racial
tensions in the area the season is a
real breeze to watch and it has personal
moments such as Wendy's new love
interest which mirrors Holden's in the
first season and with Bill's family and
namely his adopted son Brian these
really elevate the show above your
typical crime show and hammer home just
how much of a burden this all is the
show really discusses whether evil
people are born that way or if it's
caused by environment and as a fan of
psychoanalysis it was thrilling from
beginning to end every character gets a
chance to shine here and even aging Greg
who in the prior season wasn't a big
player it gets quite a big role here
showing how most normal people would
deal with questioning a serial killer a
creative team absolutely nail it here
and it really can't be overstated how
there's a noir feel to the entire work
that really grounds it and leaves a
feeling of unease for the majority of
its runtime
Damon Harryman absolutely nails Charles
Manson and after his portrayal of the
man in Once Upon a Time in Hollywood I
think he's pretty much cemented himself
as the best person to ever play him this
season is phenomenal and all of these
aspects add the overarching Atlanta
murders and why they are able to catch
the killer holding an axe a plan to turn
the car's arrogance on himself and they
control the media in order to force him
into making a mistake and revealing
himself things on easy though especially
with anger from civilians but Holden
sticks to his profile to drive the
investigation and eventually they manage
to track the killer down the murders are
committed by Wayne Williams and the show
depicts the real-life events of his
capture as it happened in a bridge
surveillance team stopped his car after
hearing a large splash and after his
alibi is discovered two
completely fictitious he becomes the
number-one suspect
though it's similar to the show he was
let go at the scene is due to nobody
being found however after a body was
found they were able to bring williams
in for questioning and after he failed
three lie-detector tests and fibers were
found that linked him to the crime he
was arrested the show differs from this
slightly as in that Holden discovers
Wayne's talent recruitment is actually a
guise to hunt children with and through
tracking the killer they are able to
catch him Williams didn't taunt the
police as much as he did in the show and
the investigation wasn't brought to a
close due to a neighbor discussing how
he's always outside burning garbage
Williams did hold a press conference at
his home now and was pretty arrogant
throughout even to this day maintaining
his innocence it's a really thrilling
finale and it expertly demonstrates the
investigation that went into bringing
Williams down as well as how difficult
it was for the FBI's new way of thinking
to be accepted unlike the first season
the FBI returned to glory and fame but
it's a bittersweet moment and you get
the feeling that the children's debts
will never be brought to justice and
that the families will still have no
answers as to what really happened the
laces the show with the tone that Holden
has created something that he no longer
controls and due to all of their
obsessions with the work over what
matters
every character seems to end with an
unhappy clothes bills wife and son leave
him Wendy is left alone with no human
contact and Holden sees that though the
killer has been caught there's no solace
for the family as even today Wayne has
never been linked to the children's
deaths we close with BTK participating
and salva fixation in a motel and this
place into my season three predictions
those who are aware of that case will
know that B TK was not actually caught
until the 2000s and with the show being
primarily set in the latter part of the
20th century rather than how it's closed
a thing that he will either be teased
throughout the next season as per the
last two you and we may even get a time
jump to show how bill has adjusted to
life without his family and how Holden
has went on to become a huge success
that is held in high regards even if he
has doubts as to whether his work is
doing all of the right things that it
should be BTK will of course play a huge
villain but with the show rumored to be
running for five seasons i imagine that
they may hold off on him for a while
however due to the deadline that his
capture presents the show will certainly
have to put at least some time jumps
into place in order to bring it up to
his eventual arrest
I think the following season will still
focus on his investigation but perhaps
per other cases in place on the road to
it this season moved heavily away from
interviews and more towards
investigations by its close and I think
that the third season may shift back to
showcase more infamous killers such as
Ted Bundy and the psychological insight
that he provided overall I'm really
excited to see where this show goes and
I found this season thrilling throughout
and a massive improvement over the prior
work this dramatically balance many
aesthetics and pulled them all off which
made for a brilliant watch I found mind
hunter season 2 gripping and that's why
it gets a 9 out of 10
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the show and what you'd like to see
in season 3 comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out my full breakdown of the
ending of season 3 of The Handmaid's
Tale which would be linked at the end in
it I go over everything about the show's
final episodes so it's definitely worth
watching if you want to know more if you
want to come talk to me about movies TV
shows games and comic books then you can
follow me on twitter at definition YT
it's the best way to get in touch with
me and it's the perfect place to suggest
new videos and content so hopefully I
see you over there after this I also
just want to let you know that we're
giving away a free copy of John wick 3
on blu-ray and all you have to do to be
in with the chance of winning is to like
this video make sure that you subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on mine hunter season 2 in the comment
section below
the 1 will be chosen at random on
September the 10th and the blue arrow be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]